[Music]
who's on the phone Paulie Ted Davis
Milwaukee Bucks radio play-by-play to
settle this Ted thanks for joining us on
short notice but there's a lot at stake
here can you I want you to listen to us
try to pronounce the Greek freaks name
and then you decide who is the closest
here Seton play the first one gianna
sunta took combo alright give me the
next one Janice I see the combo all
right right number three honest I'm
tactical who I'm poopa no it's not
closed for is who g honest ante tu
cumple alright that's pretty en scene
yiannis huntington comp oh alright Ted
you do this for a living how do you
pronounce who's closest to the correct
correct pronunciation who was the second
one second one let's pop past Nets
Paulie G honest I she's a combo uh
you're the closest it is it is yiannis
adetokunbo a debt a debt tokunbo yep the
oddest adetokunbo oh man you just
totally thrown us into disarray you want
the back story real quick yes he's
actually from Nigeria his parents
immigrated from Nigeria to Greece where
he was born he was born in Greece well
there's a Nigerian spelling of the name
that is completely different than the
Greek spelling and so that's why when
you go Greek you get all that adds a
typical combo stuff in there if you just
break it down to that the Nigerian
pronunciation the way he says it it is
yiannis adetokunbo adetokunbo yep like a
debt the cornball oh well that doesn't
sound that tough see once you kind of
look at it see what he was drafted I
looked at the name and I thought holy
crap I've got to say that name every
night and for about a half a year i just
called in the alphabet and then I
finally figured out to say adetokunbo
and now you know what he's to the point
where we just calling me honest well
even last night with the game-winner
against the Knicks you're not even
saying his last day there's no no well
you know at some point when you become
really good you become shack or you
become Michael you know or you've come
Katie
or something you don't have to have a
last name and so I think right now he's
yiannis how great well how good is he
how Greek can he be I've been doing this
for 30 years and I have never seen a
player as freakishly athletic as he is
now he's not as good as Michael Jordan
or LeBron James or some of the other
great players but athletically I don't
think the league has ever seen anything
like him a near 7-foot guy who can run
the floor like a small forward handle
the ball like a guard and he can defend
all five positions and the strides that
he takes the ground he covers with one
or two steps I've never seen it in the
NBA and he's a young guy who I think is
starting to blossom bloom like a
beautiful flower and he is now beginning
to understand how good he is and how
good he can be I kind of have to pinch
myself I mean he was the 15th pick
unknown coming out of Greece and I'll
tell you right now he's at least one of
the top 10 players in the NBA if not top
five who would you trade him for oh man
somebody happened at the other day would
you trade Anthony Davis for him yes yeah
you know you'd think about it for a
minute but no because I think he's more
versatile than Anthony Davis but beyond
that I'm not sure there's anybody I
would trade right now that the guys only
he just turned 22 years old no I and II
he's putting up these kind of numbers I
Ted on the way out give it to us one
more time the pronunciation is got it
adetokunbo Ted thanks for joining us all
right thank you Dan that's Ted Davis the
Bucks play-by-play guy the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]